il faut absolument que je fasse
découvrir les nouveautés TCL suivez-moi
c'est par là ça c'est une télé qui est
idéale pour les gamers on a du 144 Hertz
natif HDMI 2.1 on reste sur une C7 ici
on est sur du 85 pouces elle est énorme
et on peut même monter jusqu'à 98 pouces
4K HDR 120 Hz elle est idéale pour le
cinéma et gaming ici on est en mini live
tu LED et en 144 Hertz l'utilisation va
être très polyvalente de jour comme de
nuit on a les noirs de l'olyde la
luminosité de la LED et la restitution
des couleurs du cul LED ici on a le top
du mini LED avec des contrastes encore
plus précis c'est du mini LED au D5 et
on a également une barre de son 1000
watts enveloppante immersive 7.1.4 mais
gtcl vous avez aussi des machines à
laver ici on est sur un modèle compact
on a un moteur à induction et une
capacité de 6 kg ici on a un moteur à
induction une grande capacité 74 litres
mais vous avez également des
réfrigérateurs et si c'est un
réfrigérateur combiné 55 cm de large
extrêmement compact et si vous avez un
multiple cross d'or avec une très grande
capacité de stockage à l'intérieur et
vous avez en plus ici un format
américain avec d'un côté et le
réfrigérateur de l'autre côté le
congélateur